[Music]
on this Friday night exclusive access to
a new Canadian military mission
the Royal Canadian Navy navigates a
highly disputed part of the world the
training involved
Mackenzie gray reports from the South
China Sea Ukraine's president calls this
a crime against humanity
Russia's latest deadly assault plus the
rising attacks within Russia
frightening flight
hard-stopping moments after a passenger
opened the exit door mid-air plus trashy
and proud apparently I'm just known as
the dumpster Diva when garbage and
Couture collide
global national with Fara Nasser
good evening to you thank you for
joining us Global News has been granted
exclusive access to a new Canadian
military mission in the highly
contentious South China Sea where China
is growing its military presence
Beijing has long been pushing the
boundaries in the area one of the most
important and fiercely disputed
waterways in the world it's even
building and fortifying artificial
Islands to assert its dominance coveted
and contested the sea has been simmering
with sovereignty disputes for some time
we'll get to why a little bit later in
the newscast but first to hmcs Montreal
right now sailing from Singapore into
the South China Sea part of operation
projection with a goal of firming up
peace and stability in the fragile
region our Mackenzie gray is traveling
with the crew for more than a week and
he begins his coverage tonight showing
us What It's Like on board McKenzie far
we've been granted exclusive access to
hmcs Montreal as it sails through some
of the most commercially important and
politically sensitive areas of the world
with the brow lowered
and the guns at the ready hmcs Montreal
set sail from Singapore headed into the
South China Sea we have to make a public
and open statement and a clear display
of our commitment to this International
order that statement operation
projection exercises and engagements
throughout the indo-pacific to try and
limit Chinese influence in the region
but to meet those objectives The
Montreal's crew needs the right fuel
it's like
it's like a cue Jason Morgan in charge
of feeding approximately 240 people
often times in uncooperative Seas it's
like an unorchestrated ballet to work in
a galley today's Mission cinnamon buns I
tried it I mimicked uh Cinnabons and
Halifax there's nothing better than
those I can't even come close but of
those treats in three meals a day aren't
enough welcome petty officer Whalen on
board the Montreal warship this is our
convenience store Paul Whalen and his
team have you covered for a reasonable
price Kenny's a buck 75 Taco bars are
about 75 providing small Comforts from
home onto the ship when there's time to
relax just to step back and have a
chocolate bar a pop and just to take
time in and just think of loved ones
back at home but finding that time can
be tough among many tasks exercises like
this
in today's simulation the Montreal has
come under attack by two other warships
causing fires floods and casualties
a successful drill that prepares the
crew for the real thing it helps to
create muscle memory for the ship's crew
in the event that we were under attack
muscle memory on the deck and in the
ring
a key part of jean-four swan martana's
routine he's a member of the ship's
boxing club which means three times a
week despite the sweltering heat a lot
of people like to uh to keep the
training and then keep a good farm and
the physique and the mental physique
there up to a certain level while we're
gone there many members of the ship will
have been gone for six months when they
returned to Halifax in October but
pharah will be with them for 10 days as
we sail with the Montreal through the
indo-pacific
looking forward to more of your coverage
Mackenzie gray aboard hmcs Montreal
thank you Beijing says the South China
Sea is part of its territory but the
region has been the focus of territorial
disputes for several decades between
various countries in the region the
Philippines Indonesia Malaysia Brunei
Vietnam and Taiwan have all claimed
sovereignty over boundaries and Islands
throughout the area but perhaps the most
high profile dispute has been over the
spratly islands a strategically located
archipelago teeming with Rich Marine
biodiversity and potentially unexplored
oil Reserves a Russian missile attack
targeted a Ukrainian medical center
today President Vladimir zielinski calls
it a crime against humanity at least two
people died and 30 others were injured
and there are also reports of deadly
strikes on the russian-controlled areas
of Ukraine and on Russia itself as
Redmond Shannon reports the apparent
ramp up of activity comes ahead of
Ukraine's highly anticipated
counter-offensive
destruction and death 70 kilometers
inside ukrainian-held territory a
Russian missile striking a building that
housed a psychology clinic and a
Veterinary practice drones again shot
down over Kiev
in Russian held Ukraine reports of
deadly strikes too kremlin-backed
authorities claiming that a woman was
killed in the city of Donetsk and that
U.S made heimar's rocket systems damaged
buildings including two hospitals
inside Russia's borders more apparent
attacks this time in krasnodar near
Crimea and again in Belgard region the
area that saw Monday's Brazen land
incursion from Ukraine with Auntie Putin
Russian groups claiming responsibility a
rising trend of strikes on Russian
territory against military targets and
symbolic places like the Kremlin earlier
this month the New York Times reported
this week that U.S intelligence believes
Kiev was involved in that despite its
denials you're talking about that notion
of hybrid Warfare which is to both have
very real practical effects on Russia's
capacity to maintain this Invasion but
also to have psychological effects and
political effects that could further
weaken it Professor Scott Lucas says
NATO allies are broadly supportive of
these types of incursions to soften
Russian defenses ahead of Ukraine's
expected counter-offensive it is quite
clear that the Kremlin will try to turn
The Narrative of these attacks and say
look we are the victim here but I think
that is priced into these attacks in
Moscow a Chinese Envoy met with Russia's
foreign minister Sergey lavrov on a day
when Brazil's president Lula de Silva
spoke with Vladimir Putin the so-called
brics Powers China and Brazil both want
to help broker a peace deal that
currently seems almost impossible
Redmond Shannon Global News London
turning to Canadian politics in
Alberta's provincial election on Monday
it's not just albertans that are
watching the race closely future
residents are also very interested
because the province needs to attract
workers especially in the community of
Cold Lake in northeastern Alberta
because it is preparing for a boom a
major carbon capture and storage project
is in the works and if it's approved
Cold Lake will need thousands of
construction workers in the coming years
and that's not all as Heather York's
West reports the Canadian Armed Forces
Air Base there is beginning a major
expansion as well
they have been a familiar site above
Cold Lake Alberta for decades but the
flight time for these cf-18 fighter jets
will soon be coming to an end in January
of this year the government announced
the purchase of the F-35 aircraft it's
quite a different airplane in fact they
refer to it as an air vehicle more solid
an aircraft uh it's uh it's a flying
computer
has been using the cf-18 since 1982 but
much of the base here in Cold Lake is
even older dating back to 1954. the
first of the new F-35 Jets will begin
arriving in Cold Lake in 2026 but before
that can happen the base needs to
prepare and the construction needs are
massive constructions anticipated to
take approximately four years here but
yes we will have a lot of people moving
here within the next year to start
construction Ellis Dawn is currently
recruiting hundreds of workers for the
project and in a tight labor market the
company has had to bring in people from
as far away as Ontario we're expecting
pretty significant numbers so our
housing is uh you know there's room to
develop but it's a little bit tight
right now
the reality is with this project and a
major carbon capture and storage
facility proposed for the area as well
the housing market in Cold Lake could
heat up very fast the city says it's
planning for the change as best it can
watch that bud not so easy when
inflation is already hitting family
budgets hard you obviously see it in the
grocery bills and in that in the energy
bills but you're just more mindful when
you're making those purchases it's why
heading into Alberta's provincial
election affordability policies are top
of mind
[Applause]
but the community has critical
infrastructure needs too we always call
it the Forgotten highway but it's really
the main artery that comes up from
Edmonton up to Coal Lake so far the
province has committed just five million
dollars towards improving the single
Lane highway to Cold Lake but
post-election the mayor hopes to see
more invested here
with so much about to take off this
community is looking for all the help it
can get Heather urich's West Global News
Cold Lake Alberta
and Global Nationals hitting the roads
starting this weekend Donna Friesen will
be broadcasting from Edmonton on Sunday
Monday and Tuesday tune in for decision
Alberta coverages voters cast their
ballots in one of the most divisive
provincial elections in years to
Montreal next where a Heritage building
in the downtown core has erupted in
flames
the fire broke out late yesterday
afternoon and a former Monastery that
was built in 1846 150 firefighters were
dispatched to fight the Flames at least
two people were injured and 27 displaced
the building is home to condos a Seniors
Residence a daycare and one of the
city's most prestigious concert Halls it
also houses a pair of unique instruments
a harpsichord from 1772 and a fatcioli
piano the offices of Heritage Montreal
are also located in the building
it has been a difficult year in Quebec
parts of that Province still mopping up
from severe spring flooding earlier this
month water levels and major flooding
that used to be seen once in a hundred
years has occurred in three of the last
six years as Mike Armstrong explains
climate change is forcing communities to
prepare instead of react
this is a neighborhood where sandbags
are now one of the first signs of spring
this week means cleanup but that wasn't
always the case but I never thought
about it flooding wasn't something
Jocelyn say Morris says she ever worried
about the first decade she lived on the
water now with an almost annual sandbag
wall running through her property it's
hard to ignore I think that we should
prepare every year for something like
that
this flooding season was rough levels
went as high as in 2017 and almost as
high as 2019.
the difference was that people knew what
was possible there's a lot in those
previous floods I moved about 300 bags
that was Unforgettable tired I'm wasted
what that experience meant this time is
communities knew what had to be done
where there would be weak points
lost one home in this year's flooding uh
it's not comparable the mayor says in
the last floods they lost more than 50.
all these streets here where we were
sitting actually they were in canoe
people were getting out of the street in
canoe so this year they were able to be
by car
now communities are having to change
their strategies because of the
frequency of flooding it's safer to
prepare and be ready than to wait and
react we change the definition of what
is a hundred year flood Environment
Canada senior climatologist David
Phillips says we are seeing the new
reality it's not that there was never
spring flooding before it's always
happened just not this often climate
change is making the factors that cause
it more likely we're not changing the
weather except that we're making it
bigger badder and more impactful so the
water came up to uh over the first step
Bert ansel's now fought three floods he
lost his basement twice but his
Landscaping changes kept it dry this
time really making people realize what's
going on for Ansel climate change isn't
about worrying about the worst that may
happen because the worst
happening Mike Armstrong Global News
Montreal
the shows won't go on
[Music]
coming up why Superstar said India is
canceling her already rescheduled World
Tour
hey
guys
mid-air Panic on board a plan carrying
200 people after a man opened an exit
door Travelers were more than 200 meters
above the ground on route to South Korea
because the plane was Landing flight
attendants couldn't stop the 30-year-old
who witnesses say also tried to jump out
he was arrested upon landing and then
confessed to the crime the motive still
unclear around 12 people suffered minor
breathing related injuries from the
incident nine of them were sent to
hospital
in Sierra Leone's Capital people are
shattered after a living symbol of the
city's history Came Crashing Down in a
heavy storm
the 70 meter Tall Cotton Tree is
believed to be around 400 years old the
oldest of its kind in the West African
nation when the first freed slaves
arrived in what was later called
Freetown they offered prayers at the
tree and as time went on Freetown
expanded around the tree seen as a
symbol of freedom and the Heart of the
City Sierra Leone's president has
pledged to put something in its place to
honor the West African nation's history
Celine Dion has canceled all her
scheduled world tour dates through next
April
[Music]
42 European shows have been canceled
including stops in France Norway and
Ireland the Quebec Superstar is
struggling with a rare neurological
disorder that causes muscle spasms it
affects her ability to walk and to sing
Dion apologized to her fans saying I'm
so sorry to disappoint all of you once
again the 55 year old says she hopes to
be back on stage again one day the
tickets are being refunded
[Music]
swapping cocktails for mocktails ahead
who's fueling a new sober surge
with sunny skies and warmer weather
patio season has arrived for much of our
country that usually means enjoying a
cold beer or maybe a glass of wine yet a
new trend suggests more Canadians are
choosing to take a alcohol a day
switching out their Spirits for zero
proof beverages for the new reality this
week Sophie Louie looks at the growing
sober curiosity movement and the younger
generation driving it Sophie it was
practically a rite of passage for teens
and 20-somethings to experiment with
alcohol and sometimes indulge just a
little too much well now research shows
gen Zed is drinking 20 percent less than
Millennials who in turn are drinking
less than gen xers and Baby Boomers but
that doesn't mean they've stopped
partying
Elizabeth gascoigne is the founder of
absence of proof she organizes booze
free events in a number of U.S cities
where people can socialize without the
alcohol they still serve beer wine and
Cocktails all of it zero proof I would
say the majority of the people that come
to our parties probably identify
somewhere on the sober curious spectrum
and what that means is they are
intentional about their drinking but
they're not completely sober and there's
been a surge of non-alcoholic products
on the market many of them Canadian this
is from Quebec this is when I talk about
those Quebec breweries that were first
onto Market producing world-class
product this is one of them
at the drive canteen a cool and curated
convenience store in Vancouver non-elk
drinks are their best selling category
initially we started with a much smaller
selection and we realized that there was
a great community and so we wanted to
expand upon that the trend is in line
with recent recommendations from the
Canadian Center on substance use and
addiction to limit alcohol to two drinks
a week but sober curiosity is definitely
generational
I would say the harder people to
convince of the concept are folks that
are a little bit older and maybe do have
that notion of like well are you in
recovery or I don't I don't want to be
sober I don't want to be associated with
that but gen Z is like yeah I don't
really feel like drinking and they're
much more open to the the concept of
sober curiosity and there are so many
made in Canada aspects to the sober
curiosity movement we'll introduce you
to a successful BC winemaker who
switched sides shall we say now he's
taking the alcohol out of his wine
altogether and I even had a chance to
have a sample of it find out how that
goes on the new reality Bara thanks
Sophie and as Sophie mentioned you can
learn more about this alcohol-free trend
on the new reality Saturday on global
Fashions fade style is eternal
especially sustainable style next a
surprising source of these designer
threads
[Music]
now to the Canadian designer turning
trash into fashion padina bandar is
weaving her magic using garbage yep
literally garbage to create garments
that are absolutely glamorous her
clothing both durable and Chic is now on
display at a new exhibition in Toronto
as Mike drolet explains it's amazing
what you can do with plastic waste
what an odd name for an exhibit refuse
we certainly weren't refused entry to
padina bondar's First solo show which
features clothes that are total garbage
thank you as long as they're not too
trashy Ah that's right it's pronounced
refuse because everything here had a
previous life in a trash bin so garbage
You're darn right it is I think we're
very quick to dismiss things as garbage
and my goal here is to kind of show the
most extreme transition of this material
so this boostier with its woven patterns
was once trash bags yeah one of the most
intricate things I've ever made and
you'd likely guess nylon was woven into
this glamorous piece in lieu of the
plastic and wrapping paper it's actually
made from it's soft it's comfortable
plastic waste as you may have guessed is
a big issue for padina the Great Pacific
Garbage Patch is twice the size of Texas
and despite many countries Banning
single-use plastics it's not getting any
smaller and it's no secret per capita
Canada is one of the most wasteful
countries on Earth less than one tenth
of plastic waste Canadians produced is
recycled leaving more than 3 million
tons to end up in landfill
so where most of us see waste padina
sees well garbage of course but also
potential I'm not the most fun house
guys because I actually do care and I
look at people's garbage all the time
and I'm like hey like you can use that
in like a few more times you can just
like wash that and reuse it and what she
creates wouldn't look out of place at
the famous yet avant-garde Met Gala in
New York that she says would be a dream
until that glorious day padina will
continue to work on her craft making
clothes and jewelry diving for supplies
apparently I'm just known as the
dumpster Diva and keeping her eyes open
for treasure that was once someone
else's trash microwave Global News
Toronto
and that's global national for this
Friday night I'm far enough sir and on
behalf of our whole crew I want to thank
you so much for spending part of your
evening with us tonight's your Canada is
the Waterfront in Sydney Nova Scotia
with the world's largest fiddle in the
background until tomorrow take care of
yourselves and take care of each other
good night
[Music]
thank you